[Music]
in surprise news supply Beach submitted
by mall vector mall
see you at the mall now a teenager
slipped into a four-day coma and woke up
to quite the surprise did he wake up to
somebody sucking his dick [ __ ] happens
but with women or his dicks gone much
sadder wait what do you mean like
there's a lot of the pregnant ones
yeah like had a baby a girl got pregnant
while she was in a coma
the nurse was raping get like the Kill
Bill she my name is buck I like to [ __ ]
yeah I was good well so this story here
so her name is ebony she's 18 years old
from England oh yeah
England Anthony ah ha a bone a and so
she had this very rare undiagnosed
condition that meant she had she has two
wounds walls who she's missing wound in
a very cute way that first like two
wounds wait a wound are we are we so she
okay could she get pregnant at different
times where like once five months old in
there and one's yellow she kind of could
Oh was what happens you need a double
Buster though she got pregnant
yeah she got pregnant both in one of the
rooms but the womb that was behind the
other no so she never knew she was
pregnant and so she was still getting
her period normally from that the other
room run holy yeah is she fat no because
the baby was in the back so she was
gonna [ __ ] hate born greeted so we
don't look all crazy yeah side and we're
like yeah I'm pregnant can you tell
that's time that would be titus buck
all the time you know you're gonna have
a lower back hump like a turtle
so she didn't know so evany went to she
went to bed with a headache and then
later on her mom found her puking and
experiencing seizures oh when the mom
called you know for an ambulance and
then that's when the ambulance came she
noticed the bump in her daughter's
stomach at this point because of the
seizures
it moved baby to the front oh yeah so
then the body's so dope the paramedics
they were like she's pregnant and then
the moans like there's no way she's
pregnant and then they're like yeah
close them up know that she's so much
sure the mom of course yeah there's no
[ __ ] way my daughters and [ __ ] no
[ __ ] you [ __ ] trust me no yeah yeah
well I mean I guess because she saw her
have her periods I don't know who knows
so then at the at that point they took
her to the hospital she had an emergency
c-section oh no did she know she had two
wombs no that's when they found out
undiagnosed condition here does she know
when she was having like six periods a
month that's just true that's a long
time though some are like three days and
some confess did she know when she has
like double PMS and she's literally
[ __ ] slain yeah after one's done the
other one gets by I wonder what her
hormone balance is like with that many
whoa dude I bet her I've been hurt
boyfriend her husband her so much yeah
like he's like oh no she's on her period
and he's like a whole little butt
against the wall and then her hands come
through the wall that level man that PMS
not [ __ ] with a dude oh yeah I think
that's just a normal Nicki level of PMS
true you know it's crazy though like at
least for her mom because just three
hours after her first seizure she
already gave birth to this only three
hours good for her so she didn't know
she would run an errand and she woke up
their baby
well her days later because she was in a
coma
that oh my god look up after a coma with
the newborn baby she was like what
uh-huh like Jeevan whoa I shouldn't even
know she was pregnant or had two rooms
or suffered from seizures and she woke
up four days like the whole seizure
thing it was from this complication and
that women get in their pregnancy
sometimes it's called preeclampsia
preeclampsia preeclampsia kids you don't
know you're pregnant the whole time
you're looking though and then you just
go into asleep for a couple of days and
you wake up with a kid you're like okay
[ __ ] tight let's keep going number
two Meaghan in my other womb the thing
is here is that the doctor said that her
baby girl who she named Ella D is a
miracle baby
because women that have this condition
they die no it's really hard for them to
get pregnant or it's even like have up
carrying a baby to full term what she
did she was letting guys bust nuts in
there though she's looking guys boss
yeah ups to the deuce is less than such
as a strong low yeah nobody ever props
the dude though usually this doesn't
happen but your [ __ ] was such a heavy
load potent man in this scenario in this
we said I think we can thank the guy
thank you for having the truck but in
every other scenario that even know
about him
thank you for having the balls to do
that though thank you yeah so here's the
photos I'm traveling come there buddy so
she said like she feels bad at admitting
this but when she first met her daughter
that they asked she asked doctor or
nurses to take the baby away cuz she's
like what like yeah she didn't miss this
she wasn't expecting to develop a
relationship with the baby she's on a
lot of drugs turned out she had to go
buy all this baby [ __ ] Genevan no this
is this is a great room she's cute she's
a white girl named Anthony her name so
she owns a whole time I thought she
would have been black
this is her mom she's only 18 yeah baby
looks like a doll
yeah it doesn't even look real and maybe
it's cute yeah so then the baby's like I
didn't know I was gonna happen either
baby looks like a Supreme Court justice
baby
roasted that baby boy know a lot about
the wall dude yeah so they don't her
baby daddy so I don't know what the
situation is with that I'm assuming he's
white but his name's Tyrone what he
wanted a name Tyco what the name that
you kept going with was uh Giulio Jaleel
Oh or Camille's like to Lil Wyte yeah
these are those Jameel know is it Jamil
Giulio I mean there's not that much of a
giggle that's interested in his sibling
Tyrone but it's Isaac who's a child this
is a grown man ready let's follow those
names Giulio there's nothing wrong with
it
beautiful name the name Tyrone they're
beautiful names I just don't think it
fits us why I don't know a little yeah
it's a little off the same way you
thought evany and you were about Darius
Tigers like perfect right what I hear Ty
Cobb like that's perfect right because
he's like this mixed like Julie all just
doesn't sound Oh like Tiger Kwan sounds
like it goes together yeah even on Jill
do white it doesn't tell me earth cool
sounds oh that's yes Stephen Arkell yeah
fun every time I hear him called Jaleel
I'm like mm they're cool
I loved when he turned into Stefon
Stefon Stefon when he was yeah we're
party he would go inside and come out as
sit step on hmm that's so cool I always
felt bad cuz I was like damn he can't be
himself like the only way she'll love
him I didn't like Lauren for that
yeah okay Karl windows in my movie funny
story
oh really yeah at the end that's dumb I
had a crush on herbal but then I also
had a crush on Stephane so I like had a
crush on Oracle yeah I like nerdy dudes
I also like screeching I say about them
no yeah you see you guys there you have
it there is someone for everyone there
my mom would always try to sway me to go
with the q1j like just like no come on
like the other one she likes Mario Lopez
but that's the AC Slater yeah mom she
just called you you did it first though
you sure did
no white outside child or it is it's all
good I have Mario Lopez qualities
deliberate couldn't even deliver it
terrible oh man oh yeah this is crazy
oh you guys so she was saying like I
didn't even her evany was saying that
she never thought that she would be a
young mom obviously and that she thought
that she would be having kids like ten
years how old is she 18 if you're gonna
have sex just expect to be a young
whatever because it can happen at any
time so as soon as you have sex just
know that when I have sex I might be a
parent no I was so paranoid about be
careful I was on birth control pills and
condoms with lubricant that had the
spermicide in it and I made him pull out
I was so [ __ ] paranoid guys that's
not fun I didn't I was teenager I knew
one of my co-workers when I was working
at the book start college she would make
her boyfriend wear two condoms I don't
know what that was her logic doin
when mythbusters' was running out of
ideas they should have filled a Jacuzzi
with common than had chicks get in to
see Addison no the myth is if there's
come in a Jacuzzi not a Jacuzzi Phil oh
you know how they always like take it
and like they like William wrap it up
yeah look that's where it wouldn't end
up with
no Jacuzzi would come only in guys to
fill up that ship Wow and that'll
probably only be like this month a
jacuzzi come do you know what probably
volunteer Gena we do it yeah she's like
in the freaky [ __ ]
does she like come here and I do though
oh she likes come home she actually
likes come mmm you did the two condom
thing no no do you like comedy Craig oh
I like your [ __ ] be hell yeah baby [ __ ]
yes good answer phone that's a really
good answer
I was listening what were you guys
talking you're mentioning how much you
like [ __ ] I did not say that that's what
we were talking about I know that's what
you were talking about but then I was
talking about something what were you
talking about
I was saying that I was also paranoid
when I was young having sex but you
still have Isaac though could you
already know why we tried to get
pregnant that's how I got pregnant so
young because I believed a lot I was
very naive so what did you believe that
live you should have a kid um
no so it was more like hey you know I'm
already settled like this and like you
know I got my own place take care of you
whatever I want to have a kid and I'm
like okay let's do it
I just forgot that I was 17 so let's the
dumb part where I was really naive and I
was really stupid thinking that I had
already lived a full life I'm like oh
I've done my partying days I'm cool like
I could do this I could be a mom and so
that's when we intentionally got
pregnant but I'm saying before that
though I was I was on birth control
before I even had sex like I was just
like okay just cuz it tasted good
no the birth control patch
oh I never had to think about it but
yeah so I I mean if you're careful
enough and you're not dumb you should
not how come you're on birth control
before you started having sex because I
was that paranoid like I just want you
thought the [ __ ] essence of come
would be that's stupid superstitious
like hey I want to make sure that I'm
okay before the moment happens it makes
your skin really clear to when I got off
it my skin broke out and there's a
controlled your hormones yeah and also
some people are just on it because
they're they're cramps are really bad
and it makes your cramps less yeah
there's a lot of virgins on birth
control because you know just told me
she's had an ovarian cyst I think if
you're on birth control your slip that's
what I think and I stand by that comment
on ER
[Music]
[Music]